So what happens if you just make up an
IP address and port and try to NC to it?
Well, depending on the address you pick
you might get any of several different
results.
NC might exit immediately.
Or, it might just sit there and
do nothing for a while and
then eventually exit with an error
saying that it timed out.
You might have sometimes seen
similar errors from a web browser,
talking about a connection timeout.
TCP has a number of built in timers.
If it takes too long to hear back from
the server we're trying to connect to,
TCP will abandon the attempt
to make a connection and
give an error to the application.
There's another different timeout from
when our end has sent some data but
the other end hasn't yet responded.
So when you're building applications
up at the web level that's something to
keep in mind.
Sometimes you'll send a query
to another endpoint and
you won't get anything back.
And whether the default behavior is
reasonable depends on an application.
That's why various libraries,
such as Python's requests library,
have the ability to set
a timeout on queries and
notice when that timeout has elapsed.